Five four, three, two, one.
Yes.
And realize Brian Calvin,
we are live on the Internet in
cashmere right now. Everybody. Me,
how come you don't wear watches? You
were just saying I don't wear, I don't,
I was thinking as I was saying Brendon,
I go,
you could rob my house and there's
nothing you'd find a value.
Like there's not a viking thing.
It's still your car. Oh, okay. Oh no
wonder why you make money then.
Yeah, well got a lot of money. Right?
You can totally like not work for years.
I, yeah, I have enough. I make money.
But uh, I never thought I was thinking
about that too. I can, I genuinely,
I did some soul searching about this
because I watch how motivated Chavez,
he's so buttoned down about his stuff.
He's just always coming up with ideas
and I don't think I ever gave to Fox for
real about fame or
money and I still don't,
I have a very precarious
relationship with that.
What I love is coming up with new ideas
and writing new stand up and you know,
like now having done the album,
now I've got to come up with a whole new
bag of tricks that that's a really fun
time.
I'm probably more happy or never as happy
as when I'm on the road at some cafe
somewhere coming up,
solving problems,
coming up with new ideas and surprising
myself, everything else, you know,
I like hanging with my boys and
laughing and like having a nice house.
Do you get any pleasure out
of having a nice house? Yeah,
but uh, I could live, uh,
I'm have lived in rudimentary places
and I have, I don't notice. Yeah,
I noticed that when I, when I first
started making money, you get,
everything gets normal. Like this
is your house. Wake up. It's normal.
You know what doesn't change wouldn't
always makes you feel good as views.
I was about to say that I can't
believe you just said that you use not
underrated. No views or views are very
underrated. I so interesting you say that.
I had just said that, you
know who else said that to me?
Ray Kurzweil. Really? Yeah.
He always lives in a place with a
view. Yeah. When I interviewed him,
he was on a very high floor in an
apartment building in San Francisco.
That's where he lives.
And You out,
you look out from his apartment and you
see the city and you see the bay and
it's beautiful. Yeah. It's expensive. Yes.
He said views are very important to him.
They are.
But I have another weird thing that
like if you put me in a French cafe,
there's a, there's a, I don't know if
it's still around, but there was a fuss.
I'm so French Seo and that we should pop.
We'll see.
Go homoe uh, so my accent as far as
say, Ham Sandwich, the jazz for him,
I said I speak French fluently.
Say Hummel, come home.
Do Shambu how well do you feel
much speak it fluently? No, I mean,
I used to speak it. I went to
French schools in Lebanon. Yeah.
Um, you know, I mean I can give me,
give me six months and I'm going to,
you'd hop right back in then.
I think so the dating pool and frauds.
Shelly,
what were you saying?
You're about to say something
about you were in a cafe in France,
there's a place called
Chez Paul, which is, uh,
this restaurant where you're crammed
in with a bunch of people and,
and the walls and the wood has been there.
You know, you go to the comedy store,
like a comedy, like a comedy club that's
been around since the 70s. I yourself.
Yeah. And you think these are the
wood in this. This is a weird thing,
but the wood in his walls has, have
absorbed so much laughter and good energy.
I was just saying that the other day
about the ice house. Ah, it's, it's,
it's very special. If they
ever dump, demolish that,
God forbid I would buy that wood
and put it up on my walls. Oh,
so you do get to match stuff.
Yes. Magical stuff. Yes.
I like things that last,
I like marble and,
and heavy would like old railroad tracks.
Reclaimed wood. Yeah, I like this table.
Yeah. Good leather. Who reclaimed wood?
Yeah. A man with a mustache. Handmade,
things like that are handmade.
I do craftsman like, like,
like if I had,
if I wanted to,
I would maybe go and have my shoes
made in London. I'd have bespoke shoes.
Bespoke. Yes. That when they use that
high, now I'd have bespoke shoes.
The problem with jewelry watches,
nice shoes and everything is I,
I'd have to maintain them
and I, I'd rather have. Mm.
I also think we have to maintain
watches. Just put them on. That's right.
But I have a weird,
I have another weird thing,
which I think if I have
leather under my feet,
I don't feel as secure and I don't
feel like I can run or fight. Oh.
Like leather soles. Rubber Bro. I gotta
yeah, you should have some tread. Yeah,
they can put some leather tread below the
rubber tread rather. Blow the leather.
You don't want those scuffed
up leather bottom shows, man,
those bitches are useless. I've been on
socks. Right. But it's good for pivoting.
If you want to pivot, like you want to
throw a wheel kit, it's really good. Yes,
it's true. If you want to
bear down, if I want to,
let's call it squash the bug when I
throw my right and squash the bug with my
and my back foot. No,
because you want to push off.
You want to have some something to push
off. You don't need that much pivot.
You really need pivot with a
kick. A spinning kick. Yes. Yeah.
So this is, this is the kind of
bullshit you and I still talk about it.
52 it's so with that,
you're going to end well.